[موسيقى] شُيدت جدران دوبروفنيك عمدًا مما أدى إلى منع موقع المدينة كمفترق طرق بحري يعود إلى القرن السابع يتطلب قدرًا معينًا من الحماية والحماية في [الموسيقى] حيث شارك الجميع بما في ذلك الرهبان المختبئين بعيدًا في هذا الدير الفرنسيسكاني ، القبة ذات الصوتيات المثالية لا يمكنها مقاومة الرهبان فعلوا أكثر من فريسة ، كما أنهم يديرون واحدة من أقدم الصيدليات في العالم ، ويبدو أن بعض هذه الأدوات العتيقة قد تقتل أكثر من العلاج ولا تزال كتب وصفات الكمادات القديمة والمساحيق موجودة المقلاة التي تبدو وكأنها فخورة بحق بالالتزامات التي تم تحملها أثناء الطاعون ، لا تنس أن دوبروفنيك لا يزال موجودًا فقط لأنه كان قادرًا على البقاء على قيد الحياة وحماية شعبه أثناء جائحة القرون الوسطى ، بما في ذلك الطرق المبتكرة لدفع المرضى دون نشر المرض هذا هي الطريقة التي ستعمل بها ، سيكون هناك قسم يتم تمرير الدواء عبر الرمز المميز  يتم وضعها في الصندوق
حيث ستبقى إلى
أن يتم حفظها ، ثم يتم استعادتها حقًا ،
هذا هو المثال الأول للدفع بدون تلامس.
وماء الورد جيد بما يكفي
للقرن الخامس عشر وهو
جيد بما يكفي لي
[تصفيق]
تنشيطًا